team-spirit certainly a legend in his
own time an amazing man larger than life
hey dear
everybody knows the name James Beard
they might not know exactly who he is
but they know his name when this man
speaks master chefs listen this is James
Beard this is Sarasota unbleached flour
let me tell you what unbleached means
many of the chefs who join us here on
the dish are recipients of the
prestigious James Beard Award which
honors all aspects of the food industry
but not as much as known about the man
whose face graces the metal a new
documentary by PBS American masters
explores the life of America's first
foodie yes he liked beef wellington but
he liked chipped beef on toast
he loved macaroni and cheese he
appreciated a great ham sandwich his
glasses would be down on a chain and you
could see what he had in the previous
meal on the glasses it was one of the
founding fathers of eating well and
carrying on about it and gossiping about
the other people who are doing it
he gave us benchmarks for eating for
cooking and for living Kathleen Squires
is a producer on the film and a member
of the James Beard Foundation and
Danielle bulu one of the world's most
revered French chefs appears in the film
to talk about the lasting legacy of
James Beard good morning to you both
welcome good morning
Kathleen let me start with you because
as was mentioned this is a man whose
name most people know but they often
don't know a lot about him so tell me a
little bit about James beer James Beard
was a true pioneer of American cookery
he was a prolific writer of newspaper
articles magazine articles and cookbooks
during a time when not a lot of people
were writing about food he was also the
first to have a cooking show on
television in 1946 paving the way for
people like Jacques Pepin and Julia
Child he was a committed mentor teacher
restaurant consultant and above all he
championed American cuisine and
ingredients during a time when the world
was always looking to Europe for
culinary inspiration yeah it was
fascinating to watch yesterday and see
the impact that he had on so many people
and a chef for you you look back to 1939
I know for him that had a big impact on
him the World's Fair and the French
restaurant love have a young very much
what impact did he have on you
those two things as well well for me it
was not the thirties or the 50s but more
when I arrived in New York in the early
eighties and how it was still alive and
still very prominent in his engagement
with the food world but the historical
part of it I mean of course he have seen
transformation happening in America with
food and I think it was really the
instigator of transforming America with
through food I didn't realize this but
he was co-founder of a program called
meals on wheels yeah but you are
co-president now absolutely to talk
about the your interest in that in his
role in that
well his role was with Gael Greene
together and a group of New Yorkers at
the time decided to create a charity to
serve meal for elderly in New York City
and today we're serving 18,000 Miller
day and it's a wonderful program and I
think it was very involved with the
community but with the country as a
whole and it was as passionate about
what both cuisine was as much as what a
ham and cheese should be yeah I loved I
loved the little chips became to be
expensive because in friend of mine
Anthony asked you in the break you know
how many James Beard Awards have you
wanted I love that you just said let me
think about what does that mean know
you've won multiple no no no I want many
personal writings via the world such as
best chef New York best chef in America
but I had mini chef mini pastry chef
move on
rising star move on best pastry chef who
won best service best wine list so I
think the James Beard Award it's really
it can after in the foundation as the
foundation was created the James Beard
Foundation after he passed because they
started with his house this modest house
down 12 Street where it all started and
I think it was a dedication to the world
of food and every professional around
the country could have a chance to have
a stage here in New York to come
cook for public and I think that was
very the initiative was fantastic and I
think the reward is national is not only
for just famous chef great chef but also
very local places and iconic places
well Kathleen Squires our producer and
chef Daniel Boulud thank you so much for
being with us it's a wonderful document
is America's first foodie kicks off a
series on iconic chefs for the PBS
series American masters starting on
Friday May 19